as the saying goes every time a
targaryen is born
the gods flip a coin he must have
dropped the one for king aerys
for at first he seemed to have dodged
the family madness
but as he grew older he began to see
conspirators everywhere
and where there were none he worked to
create them as one of his kingsguard
i saw firsthand that a king who couldn't
rule his own mind couldn't rule seven
kingdoms
we endured his reign because we hoped
his son rhaegar would ride the realm
when he ascended to the throne
but then rhaegar proved us mad at his
father and snatched leona stark daughter
of the warden of the north and betrothed
to robert baratheon lord of the
stormlands
when lyanna's father and eldest brother
demanded justice
the mad king obliged laughing
as he dispensed unsatisfied with only
two murders the mad king then ordered
john aaron lord of the vale
to execute his two wards robert
baratheon
and ed stark instead john aaron raised
the veil in revolt
ned stark slipped past royalist
centuries and raised the north
and robert won three battles in a single
day
to unite the stormlands behind him only
to be defeated by a royalist army and
forced to flee
leaving his home of storms and besieged
the hand of the king finally cornered
robert in the town of the stoney sept
and sent his soldiers door to door
searching for the rebel leader
but the villagers hated the mad king and
loved robert
and kept him one step ahead of the
soldiers until only one
refuge remained as the soldiers closed
in
all the town bells rang out hearing of
robert's plight our father
and john aaron had rushed to the
riverlands and enlisted our grandfather
hostitulli to help them
together they routed the han's army and
rescued robert
to celebrate and cement the tully
alliance our father wed our mother
catelyn
and john aaron took our aunt lysa
only a fortnight later both men rushed
back into the field
so the dragon had finally woken
while my father's servants were losing
my father's kingdoms
my brother rhaegar had been cooped up
with his
mistress whatever else i'd call her a
distraction
but now rhaegar came to his senses and
returned to king's landing
he persuaded our father to summon his
estranged friend
lord tywin lannister the richest and
most powerful lord in the realm
rhaegar himself would lead the royal
army against the usurper robert
on the banks of the trident my brother
fought the man whose wife he'd stolen
and who fought to steal his birthright
in return
in the end robert wanted it more
his hammer shattered my brother's armor
and its rubies
fell into the river like raindrops
vanishing in the current
with rhaegar's defeat nothing stood
between robert and king's landing
imagine the king's surprise a fortnight
later when he saw not stags
but lions outside his gates his former
hand
tywin lannister had come to the capitol
with a force even robert couldn't match
claiming to be loyal to the king
trusting what he wanted to believe
ares ordered the gates opened and the
lannister
forces dutifully began pillage and
murder the
king's actual loyal subjects
when ed stark finally arrived at the
capitol with robert's army
he found lannister banners hanging over
the sack city
targaryen corpses littering its streets
and sir jamie lannister sitting on the
iron throne
below him the mad king aerys whom sir
jamie had sworn to guard
lay in a pool of his own blood from a
sore thrust
through his back lord eddard might have
thanked sir jamie for doing the realm of
favor
but honorable as he was lord eddard
condemned sir jamie as a king slayer
a name he would never escape
unlike lord eddard robert appreciated my
contribution to his glorious victory
he pardoned me for my crime and even
kept me on his kingsguard besides sir
barristan selmy
who'd been wounded at the triton
fighting for rhaegar
true both of us had failed to protect
our targaryen charges but perhaps that's
what robert liked most about us
when my father presented robert with the
bodies of rhaegar's wife and two
children
ned stark hiked up his skirts and
demanded robert sent their killer to
dawn and me to the wall
but i saw what ned couldn't
robert was ashamed of the bodies and
more ashamed of his relief
he knew that rhaegar's heirs had to die
or his throne would never be safe
but glorious heroes didn't kill children
they simply didn't punish their
murderers
for 300 years the targaryen dynasty
ruled westeros
wars were still fought home still burned
and men still died but compared to the
chaos of what came before
the realm was stable and
boring the targaryens lied
thieved and killed as much as other
lords they just had dragons to answer
all complaints
until they didn't when the last dragon
died
it was only a matter of time before the
targaryens followed
by only you mean another century
which they wasted trying to replace
their lost advantage
incinerating their own palaces to hatch
dragon eggs
drinking wildfire to become dragons and
let's not forget the mad king's favorite
burning man alive so he could pretend to
be a dragon
we urged heiress to pardon brandon stark
the boy had threatened prince rhaegar
but rhaegar had stolen the boy sister
and the boy was the eldest son of our
warden of the north
who's the greater fool a mad king or the
man who reasons with him
ares saw knives in every shadow
when you told him to treat the starks
with caution you made him afraid
and what he feared he killed
i wouldn't have thought you of all
people would bother with recriminations
for brandon's death lord baelish
not after your shall we call it duel
with him
brandon was as arrogant as he was stupid
like his father lord stark who answered
aries summoned to the capital
they earned their fates but the younger
son
ned what was his crime that ares ordered
his death as well
unlike men families don't die when you
lop off their head
at the very least you should have
pointed out that loyal and dutiful ned
was living with john aaron
a proud and over-righteous lord with an
impregnable
castle and no sons of his own perhaps
you could have spared aries the
embarrassment of revolt if only we'd had
the foresight to consult you lord
baelish but i suppose first we'd have
had to know who you were
nobody knew robert baratheon either yet
he claimed the right to sit
on the iron throne he had targaryen
blood
through his mother a pretty dress for an
ugly truth
it was war and he could swing a hammer
harder than the other options
when did you know you'd lost lord varys
when robert baratheon killed prince
rhaegar on the trident
wrong you lost the war when you let ned
stark slip back into the north
neither the bloody gate of the vale or
what kalin in the north have ever fallen
they could have held out for years even
if you'd killed robert
would you let him slip through your
fingers as well
i told the court that robert was hiding
in the stony sept but the hand of the
king wasted too much time
searching the city something about the
glory of single combat
then ned stark's army arrived to save
the day
too bad lord tywin wasn't hand any
longer he would have simply
raised the town and been done with it
perhaps
and perhaps the rebels would have found
even more of the countryside flocking to
their banners
i'd almost forgotten you weren't always
so loyal to the lannisters during the
war
where are you i did my duty to the realm
when lord tywin showed up at king's
landing professing loyalty
i warned aries not to open the gates
prince rhaegar was dead
our army scattered the lion does not
stare
unless he smells meat i admire your
powers of persuasion lord varys
fuel could traffic and so many secrets
to so little avail
grand maester pycelle told aries what he
wanted to hear
that his old friend tywin was there to
save him
then aries old friend sacked the city
and his son stabbed aries in the back i
regrettable
though necessary action as were the
pardons the new king robert bestowed on
the royalists
mace tyrell barristan selmy you
king robert wisely chose order over
vengeance
john aaron wisely chose for robert but
john aaron died
then robert then ned so ended the
glorious revolution
under the targaryen dynasty westeros
prospered
gone were the petty wars of seven
kingdoms and the endless thirst for
minor glories that drove them
the westerlands enriched the realm the
north guarded it
and the reach and riverlands fed it
this harmony is what robert baratheon
shattered with his rebellion against
ares targaryen when the call to arms
came though
we did not want to answer the reach is a
gentle land
and honestly the mad king was not much
loved
but we owed peace and status to his
family
my father mace tyrell called his banners
and marched north to battle the rogue
stormlord robert
who had already defeated three forces in
a single day
and at ashford
my father won some
chastened my father for not pursuing
robert after the battle
we had cut him off from the stormlands
the seat of his power
and he had fled north with an easy grasp
of lord tywin lannister
the hand of aerys for 20 years my father
moved instead to lay siege to robert's
ancestral stronghold
of storm's end the rose would strangle
the stag as the lion pounced
so we waited but the lion slumbered and
robert slipped past the king's forces to
join ned stark
we could have lifted the siege and
deployed our armies north to aid the
crown
we could have stormed the walls of the
castle and made
robert homeless but we had ample
supplies
control of land and sea and most of all
patience our siege would succeed
eventually at little cost of life
to us if robert prolonged the war with
minor victories
our capture of storm's end would hasten
his downfall
and if robert won the war well
it would not do for him to find us in
his halls with the bodies of his brother
stannis and his sworn men
when the lion finally showed his colours
and
purged king's landing we knew our cause
was lost
my father chose the peaceful route and
bent the knee to robert
who heartily pardoned us
strange considering how we'd beaten him
and starved his brother to the brink of
death
when i came of age brandon stark of
winterfell
sought and won my hand to my father
brandon was heir to the north and a
suitable match for a daughter of house
tully
to me brandon was wild and terrifying
never far from laughter or trouble
i loved him with all the fire of her
first passion
much i came to realize as peter loved me
when peter heard of my engagement he
challenged brandon to a duel
peter survived only because i begged
brandon not to kill him i still thought
of peter as family
now i wish i had let him die
only days before my wedding when i
thought to be happy forever
prince rhaegar targaryen abducted
brandon's sister
lyanna hot blooded as always brandon
immediately rode for king's landing to
demand justice
which the mad king aerys targaryen gave
him
in his own twisted fashion
the day the raven arrived with the news
of my brandon's death
i locked myself in a room and refused to
eat for days
until my father reminded me of my duty
i was to marry eddard brandon's younger
brother
a man whom i had never met though of
whom none spoke ill
or spoke anything at all
our union would cement an alliance of
the north
vale stormlands and riverlands in
rebellion against
the mad king i was a tully
i did my duty we were married quickly
and were spared only one night before he
had to return to the field
i spent the war by the windows waiting
for a raven to hear of my son would grow
up fatherless or
at all we knew the price of defeat
i scoured the kitchens and washing rooms
for any and all
gossip robert had won and crushed the
mad king
robert had lost but jaime lannister was
now king
robert had almost won but the mad king
had become a dragon and burned king's
landing to ash
at night i told myself the war would end
soon and bring peace either a victory
or the grave i was wrong
robert won and my husband avenged his
brother and my love
but when he came home to me he could not
meet my eyes
i saw the reason by his side
many men have bastards i know and under
the strain of war
any man no matter how honorable may
forsake his vows for a night of warmth
that he may never know again
but ned stark was not built like other
men
his northern honor would not let him
sequester his shame
in some distant holdfast
all i ever wanted was to live a life of
honor
defending a king worthy of service
during the war of the night penny kings
i sought out maelus the monstrous last
of the blackfyre pretenders
who had started this whole war malice
believed that his targaryen blood
gave him acclaim to the iron throne i
made sure his blood
claimed nothing more than the dirt
around his corpse
to show his gratitude the king elevated
me to his king's guard
it was the proudest moment of my life
but that king died and i wasn't with him
not that i could have saved him if i had
been but still
i vowed to do better with his son the
young prince aerys
for 20 years his reign was peaceful and
prosperous
ares was well loved by his subjects and
respected by his lords
but as years went on aries temper soured
he became obsessed with dragons and fire
and the swords of the king's guard
couldn't defend him from the enemies he
saw lurking
in every shadow my king
[Music]
went mad but there was
hope his son and heir
prince rhaegar was everything a kingdom
could hope for in a ruler
he was strong but gentle wise and
cautious
and a good friend no matter the wounds
ares dug into
the realm we had faith that his son
would sew it back together again when he
ascended the throne
then came lord wence tourney at
harrenhal
the largest ever in westeros ironhorsed
every man against me until only prince
rhaegar remained
we each set our feet in our saddles and
lowered our lances
and charged and i fell
muddy and bruised i then watched rhaegar
present lyanna stark with the victor's
crown of roses
though she was betrothed to robert
baratheon and rhaegar himself was
married to elia martell
we all know what happened after have i
been a bit quicker with my lance if i'd
chosen a faster horse
perhaps i could have spared the kingdom
from the destruction that came after
or if i thought to warn brandon stark
against his rashness
he came to king's landing himself
demanding rhaegar return his sister
poor fool if he'd only known the depth
of aries madness
he wouldn't have dared provoke him ares
ordered brendan imprisoned
and i could do nothing but obey when
brandon's father lord rickardstark came
to king's landing to beg for his son
aerys burned him alive and i could do
nothing but watch
i had sworn a vow to a mad king
and was honor bound to obey him even
at the cost of my soul ravens soon
arrived with dark news for the king
the veil was an open revolt demanding
lyanna stark's return
robert baratheon was smashing any army
that dared face him
edward stark brandon's younger brother
was marching the whole of the north down
the neck
and had taken catelyn tully brandon's
betrothed for his own
thus winning the support of the
riverlands the king
sent ravens to casterly rock to beg his
former hand
tywin lannister for help and no ravens
returned
a plan was devised prince rhaegar would
personally lead the royal forces
now reinforced with ten thousand
dornishmen north to face
robert of the king's guard lou and
mattel and i would ride with the prince
before we left the prince confided in me
that when he returned from this battle
there would be a great many changes in
court despite my
vows to the king i confess i was excited
on the march to face robert's army we
were sure we'd win
we had superior numbers and we had
prince rhaegar
his presence lifted the spirits of our
men and he looked every inch the king he
was destined to become
but at the trident the gods played a
cruel joke
robert proved the baratheon words as his
army smashed through our lines
ruined martel was killed i fell in
combat badly wounded
and could do nothing but watch as
robert's warhammer
ended rhaegar's glorious reign
before it began and the kingdom that
would never be washed away
down the trident with his life blood
and robert spared me insisting his
personal master
tend to my wounds out of respect
you